because I'm on the point and as just
pointed out before it's harder to do it
accurately on the board instead of doing
the letter G which you guys have got I
thought I'd give you a bit of a
challenge you know I'm just gonna do a
simple shape I'm gonna do it twice for
each of the ones that you've got okay
but then after that how the visualize
are now I'm going to show you cuz I've
already you know how in are in cooking
shows they're like and here's what I
prepared earlier you know so I've
already done my answer I've measured
them really meticulously so I will show
you there under the visualizer so you
can see what the G's should look like
you compare them to yours okay but if
you put your pens and rulers down and
look up I will show you what's going on
okay so really quickly what I've done is
I've um I've taken this is my start you
remember we did this before we did our
first reflection okay now if I reflect
this again just like you had two lines
okay and the important thing not your
best these is that they're parallel do
you notice that if you read that little
conclusion that you would have noticed
it talked about that right there they're
going in the same direction
watch what happens I'll try and do it
quickly because it's an easy shape okay
so I'm gonna go here I think I'm gonna
end up about there okay I'm gonna go
that's gonna be um a - I guess you can
see that oh there further across - about
er to get B - that's about right yep and
then C - should be directly above B -
can you see that okay now here's what
I'd like you to do with me
remember these are called composite
transformations it's really one move
made up of two parts okay so what I want
you do is forget about the middle shape
for a second in fact I'm going to rub it
off so that you forget about it I want
you to look at the final shape and the
original shape okay now
think we got from here to here oh it's
obviously it's more some weight as it
went across big again we've go from here
to here by reflections right but if I
didn't tell you anything about the
reflections and all you saw was these
two shapes what transformation are you
looking at yeah you know that's
translation right you can see it hasn't
been turned round it hasn't been flipped
from here to here okay now you're ready
I'm gonna blow my other book I haven't
even done it yet watch and you'll be
able to a better job with this on your
diagram than mine
okay watch watch carefully when I
measure okay why is it that it's gone
this far what is this particular
distance well I should measure from a to
a to or from B to B to now give me an
idea right Fieger from a to a to let's
compare that now on my ruler
let's see what's that that's about we'll
have 64 centimeters by the looks of it
that's how I measure okay so let me just
put that on 64 centimeters is how far it
has moved okay now
that distance is not a coincidence okay
because if I if we all had the same
diagram and I gave you the same lines we
would all end up on the same spot that's
not coincidental but when is this
sixty-four come from I'll show you where
it comes from watch let's see how
accurately I did this okay if I look at
this here the distance between the two
lines
okay now mine is slightly off because as
I said it's under actually but it is
pretty close to 32 centimeters exactly
half of how far the final translation is
okay so here's your conclusion on your
sheet this is the way I would conclude
it you've got that sentence there it
says two reflections across parallel
lines is equivalent to translation right
two reflections across paralyzed is
equivalent to translation how far double
the distance
between the two lines yes well a little
bit I heard the fact that this is uh
these measurements here has to be crazy
okay wait I'm not done yet you guys had
a second one as well right let's do this
one okay now you might notice what's
different about it is that the lines are
not parallel but I'm still gonna do the
same reflection okay so let's do the UM
let's try and do the quick version okay
please - all right we're gonna go across
the first line first I've got this line
looks like about that length and this
line looks like it's about that leg okay
so I'm gonna try I think it'll be
something like this how's that for a um
the phosphor is that Alright okay now
the one off at an angle is a bit harder
okay so let me get on the car you need
to sort of turn your hand a little bit
to do it properly you've gotta go to
this farm sir sorry I should have said
this is DS so that'll be d1 e1 and f1
okay so now this new one will be what's
it gonna be cool this one should be um
f2 is that okay
what am i other ones okay now let's see
if I can do this accurately I think I'm
getting something like this
there you go there's a - and D - okay
now what's happened what's happened it
might be be easy to see if my triangles
than with your G okay again I've gotten
there by two reflections but I'm gonna
ask you to forget the middle one all
right
stop thinking about him there have a
look at that first shape and I find a
shape
what's happened it's a rotation isn't it
you can even see it there it goes around
like that okay
and just before right we did two
reflections we've got a translation here
we've done two your reflection so right
at the bottom of a page I'm gonna say
two reflections across northern parallel
lines in our panel right it's equivalent
to not translation about rotation now
question how far do you think it has
rotated how far is that look that looks
like 90 I think that looks like that
looks like that tipped over 90 degrees
okay
so I've gone around 90 degrees right hmm
can anyone guess what am I gonna put
onto the diagram next think about what
we did here what okay so this angle in
here right
remember how I measured the distance
between the two lines here and then the
total distance was double that well if
you've measured this angle here then the
total angle will be double that as well
okay and the thing that they're rotating
around is that point there and call that
point P the place where the two lines
meet
so I think that's really cool I'd love
you to finish that